[Musique]
deux semaines avec un patch une bonne
dose de volonté et l'envié de retrouver
un souffle normal s'il ya 20 ans a
décidé d'arrêter de fumer
progressivement de 15 à 8 cigarettes par
jour une évolution positive est
importante même si les difficultés le
sont aussi mais sans respirer je me sens
humaine et voilà les difficultés face
aux lyonnais a tout le temps il y en a
partout et dans tous les domaines et
voilà ça fait partie de du sevrage que
ce soit tabagique alcooliques ou de
drogues
donc il ya des difficultés mais quand on
atteint nos objectifs on est hyper
content pour réussir son pari célia
consulte le service tabacologie du
centre hospitalier de versailles une
aide essentielle qui doit lui permettre
d'éviter la rechute à long terme
moi je prenais la cigarette comme une
amie carrément c'était vraiment je l'âge
la gym jeu l'humaniser et est donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile de séparer
jean lamy
quand il ya des rechutes elle est
essentiellement due à la dépendance
psychologique c'est à dire que la
dépendance physique et a disparu
la dépendance comportementale aussi est
il ya une émotion qui va revenir et qui
va faire rejeter les spécialistes
parlent d'art et confirmé après deux ans
sans cigarettes chaque année en france
73 mille personnes décèdent à cause du
tabac